if nothing that's all oh my god are you
done yamimash huh well that was awful
how the great map you shut your mouth
I loved it yeah just your dingdong damn
mouth you and you me do fu give it a
chance not a chance
fine look you got my assurance discreet
that's not um of the two we've already
played oh oh I have your assurance this
is gonna be fantastic see I believe I
can trust you
I'm Johnny I'm coming to be here any
second now you are they only come I'm in
I'm in oh I'm in hell ah ah it's the
best way to start ever hello everybody
my name is barb don't don't not doc doc
no you're gonna do it I saw I saw it in
your own I thought you were gonna do it
near eyes no you're gonna do it doing
anything okay I won't put my gun again
oh why all right I won't cheat you know
I'm fine oh damn it all right are you
ready to be serious
I'm ready the people want to see
seriousness they don't want to see this
la la la la la silly all right you have
to make a real seriously okay hello
everybody and welcome to let's play you
die at the end this is a gmod a horror
map I want to say it's made by oh I do
not have the name this is so
unprofessional of me it's okay I don't
have the name my name is a mash you may
know me from some of the other videos
we've done we've played about three Maps
up to this point now and hopefully this
is gonna be um gonna be as scary as we
think it is
it will be maybe you know we can only
hope I don't have much of a tolerance
for scary things so we can only hope
ok so would you like to UM go off in
that direction and I would like you to
show me the face ah
Yolo swag Rudy let's go
keep up the seriousness but 132nd no I I
did that for a whole video of drug by
Graff people hate it oh really
hey did it little like woozi's guys is
not filled with so many scary things I
know
woo RIT what wait what is that down
there
I don't know what are you gonna picking
up huh well maybe I will
it's all shiny and you should always
touch shiny things you should shine e
buts shiny faces what is this it's light
oh really
is it ok fine okay so uh I'm shiny teeth
I was doing she's got the bling yeah I'm
gonna playing on the golden chain I got
the got the brass knuckles
yeah well this looks lovely this map is
really good scary I'm so terrified man
this is so me scare surfer are no
apparently the description of this
there's no jump scares just a really
good atmosphere oh you know should know
it's so good I can't even believe how
good it is
cuz yamimash promised it would be good
oh I fell in a hole oh nice bloosh I'm
also falling in this hole no uh-oh get
up get up I'm on round get up huh done
going up Oh get up get up get up get up
okay thank you thank you for moving okay
okay so what's in here too much what is
this taps with really ugly symbol you
you um to be go anywhere now there's no
boy to this mom you haven't given a real
chance I've haven't given you a real
chance I assured you this will be one of
the greats Matt's all time and is it ah
no oh there you go
I thought we died in the end apparently
we can't even get to the end maybe this
is our death uh hi uh I know you're you
can begin this now I will blow again ha
ha that's a start that's our center
syncing noise ok alright hello everybody
and welcome to screamer Hey after
getting tired of playing so much crap
match me and your match decided to
scream our butts off scream me what it's
so scary it's making noises want him why
I don't wanna actually don't want to hi
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do Oh No thank you
young meso is very good I did the screen
for you Wow Oh No who's that I missed it
oh no I heard something what was it Oh
what is screaming raymandy it's called
screamer good they scream I lay down my
way there's gotta be something else oh
oh god I cried a little bit wait oh no I
heard a door I heard a door oh I heard
it click on the walls okay here you
gonna be Layton good okay there we go
let's go easily
give me well mark looks like you need
some of this look is that : blue yeah
it's gonna be so good movies oh good
alright it's different alright move it
oh oh oh my god screaming things to me
from the ceiling Matt oh hell no way no
h-e-l-l-o what is that smell
he'll go oh yeah well I'm not gonna
reciprocate cuz I would be mean all this
looks good the light is flickering oh I
didn't get it oh my oh boy Oh
oh it Trump's it for eternity mom oh my
no looking at me good god ah ah these
are so I don't I don't even know what to
say it just pours you right back to here
no hang on no no that's it nice it I
probably there's nothing out I'm no
clipping about a seat there is nothing
oh my god is nothing nothing else
nothing is absolutely nothing hi
get me out of this misery control
yourself
punkin it's getting great you're my
assurance no don't give me your I don't
want your assurance you take your
assurance back damn it it's great advice
that lets you take it back damn it go
take it back damn it it's gonna be great
it's gonna be great so great we're gonna
ditch work for this one it's gonna be a
whole series great we're gonna be great
are we got a guys over for all my man oh
that's great they'll eat your sanity
just gonna regret I think mark is
finally awesome there's some boxes for
you to destroy over there oh this is
it'll hit wyant-wheeler oh there we go
I feel so much better all oh thank you
so much okay dogs bow-wow everybody my
name is Mark barn welcome to let's play
hey God
how do I go in it isn't alpha again cut
away always how are you here oh my god
oh you can do no no no no hey you know
what temporary obstacle shut up your
mouth don't care about no your ball I'm
gonna do it huh Oh like that I'm right
here here you do know I know clip Russ V
oh okay okay now Brett unpress V Darren
yeah there we go and I'm turning it off
okay we're in
oh boy oh gotta be good I gotta be great
guys
don't you consider leave my I turned it
are the door sir kinda I will go in
first so that I get the scares ha la la
la la oh my god what did I see
was it scary yeah yeah oh no I uh it was
oh it's nice to scream so bad ah kill me
Oh
ha ha I don't know Gary come on
what huh what is that when you wake up
you noticed all your women's you are
fine oh is it gonna get good huh good I
gotta say you know is it gonna be good
it's not Oh
maybe good it could be good yeah yeah I
got crowbar there you go Hey oh man you
baboom just need to find the key I know
please can you not do this please thank
you okay you do give me a second the
door is very slow these days oh look how
strong I am
oh I am let them Martha let me go
that was like it nothing a no thing only
breakup so precisely it's actually thank
you whoa wait what did I do
um is it I think yeah we did we get a
key
uh no I don't think so what's that
directly if you it's like a little uh
huh it's like a little pipe yeah I don't
know that's a shame okay right well
those that was a was that hopeful where
I was I
Exxon's I thought so he was right behind
this door yeah I know we're supposed to
go in there somehow we need to find a
rid key you'll find it I don't got it
you found a stash Egan's Larry
gone then okay oh no oh oh God oh that
was scary
adorable huh really why it's not over
yet there we go there we go hello hi oh
hi dad he's got a red key he does how
are we supposed to open that in the
first place uh I do not know oh that was
real real scary shut up I got startled
[ __ ] you yeah hello I'm Jung vas
hello hello something's behind this wall
what wall whoa Morgan Freeman I've been
looking for you why are you here who are
you oh god jack Hey
see what I mean this might actually be
good it's actually building a missile
it's billy-oh storyline
oh wait Han all right this bunker was
made in 1940 combined discovered this
bunkie twenty-two days ago they decided
to go down in it when you was one of the
new come in combine it was your job to
go down in into it when you walked
around in the first floor you got hit
and pulled longer into it good cut now
you need to find a way out of bunker
while you are down here you discover all
the weird things about bunker when you
call my goodness are you done yamimash
are you quite done are you quite done
over there he's continued well you need
to get off of me cuz we need the ghost
oh sorry go forward up jump and get off
of me
I'm sick hey hey bull Ziggler making fun
of me should be bunka I'm sick of you
and your shenanigans I've had it up to
here
oh um I you see it was seeing that was
supposed to go this way
for me who Tim you know hello
how are you huh aren't wait were we
supposed to go that way
Oh is there actually something that
worked in this game didn't window uh why
whoa she's looking at us I'm going in
oh the yabba dabba doo boo oh is it ah
oh ah cold blood no but that was banned
in nineteen countries you have obviously
not in that country right what country
are we in yamimash the country yes hell
knows the found homo we're in the red
one seems like the trap to me Mac don't
trust this I trust implicitly I'm good
baby
hey Rudy yes I did listen I saw Ramona
Luna yes just control yourself no
there's no door in the baby yeah
just made all the dust but no baby
instead this wall this wall looks
fashionable hit me
sorry it was it's okay it's control
yourself we'll find it wasn't the base
of that call what happened
it's something did I miss something you
died yeah I died Oh
ah
there is no basement it actually is
nothing I'm doing around it Oh baby that
was that was it Oh sir I just saw your
head zooming through the floor love is
it whoo whoo hey when you'll make it
hide-and-seek you got to 500 this one
isn't it brilliant
Oh Oh ha 10 yeah I'm so good I'm so
happy that we got to play this one I am
too guys oh good oh good good please
shoot me please I am the only uh the
houses only less person to humanimal Oh
I'm not human anymore I'm gonna go shoot
myself in the face with the beluga okay
there you go
oh okay thank you very weird under and
again and take it we're done yeah we're
so bad
I don't know where the hell had this
stupid socks I don't know why you keep
singing like it's a thing you know
I went to you like a destruction sphere
I never even had a possibility of
success I don't know no I don't know
what I'm doing
you [ __ ] told me the cold blow is
gonna be a sure investment you told me
that you promised me it was gonna make
us millionaires don't love people
listening do prawns money
look we'll just make a new product and
get a new name and he'll do the exact
same thing he'll kill people cuz that's
what Corvo dude it blew their intestines
yes
oh we blew it there : alright it blew
I'm dead well I've been making new bombs
because how these you mean you mean
market : blows some teducker nade
Wow yeah you didn't eat my you knew that
then when I told you you didn't see that
I thought it was actually a product a
heat for laxatives that as soon as it
hits your bowels it triggers an exploit
that's why the doll knew the document
that was like they clear up constipation
gluten you know I said it in a nice way
yes but in in a direct more I'm being
real with you
okay all right you okay all right you
know what that's all in the past now
what we do we go to the military and we
approach them with this product that
looks like food the terrorists eat it up
and then they died in an explosion I
thought I thought you wasn't no we
didn't like explosions no no now this
don't make so much sense
and you know what you know what we'd
call it la talla blow talon blow get it
get it yeah join the server a cam
joining I don't know where I'm gonna put
that